welcome back to cbs this morning cbs
news has learned that the federal
government is holding
dozens of unaccompanied migrant children
at hotels
not the those detention centers while
they await deportation during this
pandemic
so from march through june the border
patrol says it has apprehended nearly
100
000 people at the southwest border more
than six thousand are unaccompanied kids
maria villarreal is following this story
it was first reported on the associated
press from fort worth texas
maria good morning i'm still stunned by
the number of six thousand children
without their parents
good morning gail yeah that is a very
large number you know this is all
happening as the trump administration is
trying to expedite the deportation of
all detainees
asylum seekers by using a cdc order
that's in place right now to prevent the
spread
of coronavirus now in the past ice
contractors have used hotels to house
these detainees
but the issue at hand activists are
saying is the fact that they are housing
children right now by and this is
violating their rights and in addition
it could be putting them
in danger they have suffered trauma
you know getting to the united states
and now they are suffering trauma at the
hands of our government
carlo marisol vargas is an attorney
working with the texas civil rights
project
the group is now suing the government
after it recently uncovered
unaccompanied migrant children
set for deportation were being held in
hampton inn and suites in arizona and
texas
there is absolutely nothing in the
established protocol
that says that these children need to be
sent to hotels that's because u.s law
says children illegally entering the
country must be held at facilities
overseen by the government as they await
their asylum cases
cbs news has learned the hotels have
been used nearly 200 times
meanwhile more than 10 thousand beds sit
empty at government shelters
according to the associated press
roberto lopez was part of the team that
documented what it claims
is the lack of safeguards for the
children there seemed to be no security
at this site
i did not see any sort of indication
that there during a pandemic
if there were any emergency supplies any
sort of ventilators
the children are supervised by a
contractor used by ice which said in a
statement to cbs news
the transportation specialists are
non-law enforcement staff members
trained to work with minors and to
ensure that all aspects of the transport
or stay
are compliant data obtained by cbs news
shows that since
march border officials have deported
more than 2 thousand children
under an order implemented by the cdc
back in may
that order was extended indefinitely
this administration have jumped on this
opportunity
to use the pandemic as a justification
to essentially waive all asylum
protections
for individuals
hilton hotels and castle hospitality
which franchised this hotel
chain says they are quote committed to
providing safe clean
and comfortable accommodations to all
guests especially vulnerable populations
castle hospitality also says they are
complying with all lodging requirements
set on state and federal levels and in
addition they say their customers have
assured them
that they are meeting all requirements
that are set by the government
to house these groups tony all right
maria thank you very much